hello everybody my name is Nita Ambani
girl and I'm a software developer from
Nigeria I'm walking on a real-time state
synchronization service I should be able
to launch it by the end of the month
this much I currently work from home
that I do most of my walk I have a small
office set up in an unusual yeah maybe
not so small quiet okay comfortable for
me I can show you my decks now so this
is my small sand office I have just a
MacBook Pro without an external monitor
right down here I keep some small quotes
which I do meditate on for my current
product to see real-time spacing library
state sync service he just started
walking on it and I decided to start
with the dashboard party color start of
my morning with positive intent by
reading and reflecting audios away then
a chapter phone book called daily
destroyed by dying on the day I does
infesting I read after before I get
stuck my world reflect on the war zone
and then I do some gratitude and society
I buy the business that's two more you
know like this which I used today or
days which I used most of the time I've
taught the gratitude exercise I do
listen to some motivational motivational
thoughts so
to keep my mind booster de-energized so
today I listened to this record
yesterday I listened to this so they
helped me to get started with the day
with high energy and clarity and some
people to start off the idea with emails
I sometimes don't look at my email and
sometimes I quickly check my email to
see if there's any important email
coming in that this will affect how I
parent my day because I do organize my
activity for today the night before so
that I just started immediately so I
already have in mind one of God's
walking for the day after my reflection
I'm going to kick-start David's son Cody
not a Tobias laughter it gives way I
write down my activity for the day
documented because they're cold as you
are I thought the I did sacrifice the
time spent on activities only to code
come back flow which are useful in
tracking and I have various body and
it's helped me weeks time management is
that respect at the end of the week to
see how much I spent and in what areas I
spent done and it uses the Pomodoro
Technique
for me I use trains minutes time table
and in a day I aim for three to four
hours of focused work
not including great times so in total we
couldn't breathe
it's been about five on my laptop five
six times walking let's try to go for
cos walk for three to four times
sometimes during my short breaks I
stretch it's quite sunny and very hot so
I'm trying to do a small service with
slammed and it obvious London if I get
we need to use it video plays
Lamborghini I can't wait so followed
some basic instruction from the about
meditation and I've been able to set up
a quick lambda and I think the UI
despites
is it videos and I've been able to
settle some things just with the click
of some buttons and it works for me and
said that I've not been able to connect
TV I get river connected there were two
and maybe I get to do a proper response
so I'm getting and Donny quick English
which is pointed me to this resource
that I need to set a response code so
I'll be setting up the response code so
it begins properly
on this test again I expect to get
different results so he is saying
successfully completed drugs so part of
my day involves trying to figure out
some new tests so how do you stand by
going through documentation online equal
good goose as soon as I have all winter
long tutorials because they a lot of
testing and documentation now to take
weeks to ago finish on that then doesn't
need to achieve what time it touches as
soon as possible so quick do-it-yourself
an google search helps me solve this
problem so today I talk I decided to go
for Iran we need 5 kilometer today I do
this sometimes have car walk and evening
on Friday or Saturday but today are
going to my